les démocraties se défendre ça pourrait
être le titre de ce débat je vous
présente mes invités claude malhuret
bonsoir et bienvenue vous êtes sénateur
de l'allier ancien ministre président du
groupe les indépendants au sénat et vous
étiez en ukraine la semaine dernière
avec six autres sénateurs et beaucoup
d'autres personnalités on y reviendra
évidemment irina dmitri chinois soir
bienvenue responsable des études
craignent à l'institut national des
langues et civilisations orientales
benjamin haddad bonsoir les deux
chercheurs en relations internationales
directeur du centre europe de
l'atlantique on cible c'est un think
tank américain qui étudie les relations
internationales et où vous êtes auteur
du paradis perdu l'amérique de trump et
la fin des illusions européennes
laetitia coupe à l'éditeur et politiques
à rester à mes côtés claude malhuret
ce voyage de trois jours en ukraine il
était organisée à l'initiative de
l'ancien ministre alain madelin si je ne
me trompe et vous y avait notamment
rencontré le directeur de cabinet de
volodymyr rimouski qu'est ce qui vous a
demandé prioritairement la première des
priorités alors il nous a dit ne
demandant trois choses nous connaissent
et certaine la première c'est des armes
des armes des armes la deuxième c'est
persuadés les allemands demandez à votre
président d'arriver à persuader les
allemands qu'il faut arrêter de traîner
les pieds sur les émissions sur les
sanctions et origines et la troisième
c'est nous sommes des européens je vous
supplie je supplie l'europe de nous
accorder au mois de juin avant de
monsieur notre candidature non pas notre
adhésion il sait parfaitement que ça
prendra du temps mais accepter notre
candidature ait accepté d'examiner parce
que nous sont aujourd'hui les plus et il
parlait à des français qu'ils étaient
juste avant une élection où comme vous
le savez une des candidates étaient des
partisans de quitter l'europe pays nous
disait nous c'est le contraire on veut
on est probablement aujourd'hui le club
qui veut le plus
venir en europe des armes des armes des
armes finalement c'est ce qui s'est
passé aujourd'hui en allemagne irina
dmitri chine de nouvelles livraisons
d'armes annoncée par les états unis par
une quarantaine de pays occidentaux est
ce que vous y voyez aussi un signe
comment je peux dire ça de l'efficacité
ukrainienne de la résistance de ces
dernières semaines voyez ce que je veux
dire c'est aussi parce que les
ukrainiens ont prouvé leur leur capacité
à utiliser les armes qu'on leur donne
qu'on continue de leur en donner tout à
fait parce que je rappellerai que il ya
quelques semaines la masa d'heure et
craignait en allemagne a dit que le pro
dès le premier jour il est allé voir les
responsables allemands en disant donner
nos désarmé on lui a répondu mais de
quoi nous parlez vous d'ici 48 heures on
ne sera plus là donc donc en fait au
début personne ne croyait que les
ukrainiens seraient non seulement
voudrait résisté mais qui serait capable
de le faire et donc c'est plus vrai en
d'armes montre d'une part le changement
donc de
qui vient d'europe de différents partis
mais c'est aussi tout d'abord la
reconnaissance du fait que les
ukrainiens vont se défendre ils sont
capables d'utiliser ses armes alors je
vous propose d'écouter parce qu'il ya un
symbole autour de la décision prise par
l'allemagne qui va livrer des chars
guépard sont des blindés antiaériens on
écoute la ministre de la défense
christine lambrecht
nous avons décidé hier de soutenir
l'ukraine avec un char anti aériens avec
des guépards c'est exactement ce dont
l'ukraine a besoin pour sécuriser son
espace aérien depuis le sol il est clair
que l'allemagne est prête à le faire et
que nous allons examiner aujourd'hui
encore dans le cadre de la conférence
toutes les possibilités afin de
continuer à soutenir l'ukraine dans
cette lutte courageuse mais importante
pour la liberté et la paix
fringe acheter benjamin haddad c'est
important militairement évidemment mais
symboliquement aussi alors
symboliquement c'est important de le
faire parce que les allemands étaient
critiquées par certains alliés
évidemment par l'ukraine pour leur
lenteur alors pas tant sur les
livraisons d'armes parce qu'on sait que
de toute façon les allemands sont un peu
en retard 1 sur les questions militaires
ils ont commencé à réarmer depuis le
début de ce conflit mais ce sera un
processus long mais met clairement sur
les sanctions puisque ce sont les
allemands aujourd'hui qui ralentissent
les sanctions sur l'énergie contre la
russie on sait que la russie est
dépendante ou pour son pays mais à 35%
des exportations d'hydrocarbures donc ça
s'apaise sa finance tous les jours
l'effort de guerre de la russie est donc
là des pays comme la france par exemple
ont proposé de faire dès aujourd'hui
l'embargo sur le pétrole on sait que les
allemands sont beaucoup plus dépendant
que nous sur le pétrole comme sur le gaz
donc c'est une une
une annonce symbolique importante pour
l'allemagne mais aussi effectivement
stratégique puisque c'est aujourd'hui ce
qui permet aux ukrainiens de repousser
l'agression russe de rééquilibrer le
rapport de force sur le terrain et
effectivement les ukrainiens non
seulement ont démontré qu'ils étaient
capables d'utiliser ces armes et on me
demanderait leur bravoure sur le terrain
mais maintenant qu'on se prépare à un
conflit qui va être très intense très
dur sur le dombass et qui ressemblera un
peu plus à une guerre conventionnelle un
classique du char d'assaut contre chars
d'assaut sur un terrain plat qu ait
connu des batailles importantes de la
seconde guerre mondiale là les
ukrainiens nous demande de monter en
gamme dans les armements est donc
maintenant de livrer des armements plus
lourds comme des chars est ce que les
alliés commencent à faire et si on vous
quelques détails une cinquantaine de
chars dans le spécialisé dans la défense
antiaérienne qui avaient été retirés du
service il ya dix ans et qui doivent
subir une mise à jour technique c'est
aussi important de le dire claude
malhuret la la la france alors on a été
très discret sur ce que l'on faisait en
termes de livraisons d'armes peut-être
pour des raisons stratégiques on peut
comprendre là on a on annonce le fait
d'envoyer des canons d'une portée de 40
km des canons caesar est-ce que sur
cette partie là l'adresse sur la
question des armes est ce qu'il faut en
faire plus d'après vous est ce que la
france doit en faire plus
la france a un problème que n'ont pas
les autres pays européens actuellement
est une bonne excuse si je veux dire
mais c'est pas seulement une excuse
c'est le seul pays qui combat en ce
moment c'est à dire que nos armes elles
sont au mali sont dans des temps
différents pays dans des plantes
coalition et par conséquent
on a quand même de ce point de vue là un
peu plus de difficultés et notamment les
munitions on sait qu'on est presque à
cours de munitions dans les pays où on
agit et par conséquent il est sûr que la
france pourra pas faire le même effort
qu'un certain nombre d'autres pays mais
bien sûr il faut plus c'est ce que
demandent aujourd'hui comme il nous
disait tout à l'heure des armes des
armes des arbres et de ce point de vue
là les états unis ont parfaitement
compris que maintenant que vous le
disiez c'est plus 48 heures qui l'équipe
honneur c'est une fête c'est une guerre
longue est-ce que 10 des élèves ce qui
aujourd'hui c'est ça y est et il
continue à les demander mais disent hey
on reçoit des choses significatives je
dirai au delà
ce qui est frappant
quand on regarde quand on est en ukraine
et quand on parle avec les avec les
responsables politiques comme avec la
population ce qui est frappant c'est que
ça ne sonne n'apparaît pas peut-être
comme ça ici mais il est une certitude
tranquille mais tranquille c'est pas la
propagande une certitude tranquille
qu'ils sont en train de gagner cette
guerre qu'ils vont la gagner et qui sont
déjà en train a gagné avoir repoussé les
russes du nord de kiev avec très peu
d'armes à l'époque c'est déjà quelque
chose de fantastique mais maintenant je
les russes disent on va sont en train
d'essayer de s'occuper de de contrôler
tout le monde basé locaux de sud de
l'ukraine moi je suis intimement
persuadé en revenant de là bas qu'ils
vont perdre cette guerre et qu'ils vont
se faire rebouché est-ce qu'en voyant ça
vous vous pensiez peut-être au flegme
eau des populations anglaise et
britanniques pendant le blitz pendant la
première année du pouvoir de 2,8 en
sursis c'est pas ce que je pensais moi
ce que je sais à quoi je pense c'est aux
armées de serre valmy et aux armées de
napoléon quand vous parlez aux écluses
du canal 10 pourquoi on va gagner cette
guerre parce qu'on a en face de nous des
gens qui savent pas pourquoi il se bat
des soldats qu'ils ont complètement
paumé
à qui on n'a même pas dit que c'était
une guerre avec une armée de type
soviétique c'est à dire toujours la même
chose des bombardements meurtriers et
ses draps et derrière des commandants
qui ne sont pas autonomes et des ddd
vieux généraux etc et qui font toujours
la même chose et vous avez en face des
généraux de 40 vous avez les armées de
napoléon des généraux de 35 40 ans qui
ont été formés avec des méthodes de
l'otan c'est-à-dire qu'ils sont
individualisés qui sont capables de
prendre des c'est pour ça qu'ils ont
gagné avec une arme des armes en leur
défaveur parce que ils sont beaucoup
plus jeunes ils sont beaucoup plus
d'initiatives et c'est ça moi qui
m'apprend bg je compte on parle la
résistance du meuble crânien à valmy
quand il ya une levée en masse parce que
les français sont eux sont attaqué de
partout et c'est exactement ce qui se
passe chez eux et deuxièmement avec une
armée qui accueille huit ans effet formé
depuis la crimée parle par des parts des
pays de l'otan et qui est avec avec des
stratégies de défense ou d'attaqué
d'ailleurs complètement différente et
c'est sans doute effectivement une des
raisons pour lesquelles les russes sont
dans une situation très très mauvais
l'une des raisons pour lesquelles c'est
si difficile de pouvoir prévoir le cours
d'un conflit avant le début du conflit
c'est qu'on compte les pièces
d'artillerie les avions les tanks tout
ça c'est très matérielle c'est très
statique et après quand on rentre dans
la guerre c'est là que les volontés en
fait rentrer en jeu et on voit en fait
quand on parle de guerre asymétrique
c'est qu'en fait c'est aussi une
asymétrie des volontés l'exemple de
valmy il est vraiment frappant le traité
de guerre le plus connu traité moderne
c'est le livre de clausewitz le général
prussien de la guerre et claude vi avait
été frappé par les armées françaises à
valmy parce que vous aviez d'un côté
effectivement une armée nationale avec
des conscrits qui battait qui se battait
au nom de l'hymne national et de l'autre
côté encore des vieillards mais pré
moderne qui était armée de mercenaires
ou mes ouailles stockera tic et à ce
moment là effectivement vous avez une
foule galvanisée
côté français qui l'emporté c'est
exactement ce qu'on voit là les
ukrainiens sont galvanisés et d'ailleurs
quand on voit dans le donbass prennent
de plus en plus d'initiatives de plus en
plus de risques parce qu'ils sont
motivés quand on se projette dans
l'avenir aujourd'hui en ukraine on ne
dit plus après la guerre on dit après la
victoire c'est ça effectivement l'état
d'esprit en ukraine et de l'autre côté
vous avez des soldats russes qui
commence vraiment de plus en plus je
crois à se demander ce qu'ils font là
alors justement irina dmitri chine ce
qui est intéressant c'est qu'il ya eu
une partie effectivement deux soldats
deux militaires qui étaient soit déjà en
guerre parce qu'il faut le rappeler une
partie de l'ukraine qui était en guerre
ou qui se sont formés se sont préparés
mais il ya aussi une grande part de
population qui était absolument pas
formés au maniement des armes et qui a
rejoint finalement le la résistance et
le combat tout à fait j'appellerai juste
que le chef d'état major ils craignent
un est un homme qui a été formé déjà à
l'époque post soviétique c'est à dire
qu'on n'a pas de même à la tête du
commandement et dans les généraux on a
des partenaires cinquantenaire mais on
n'a pas des gens qui sont sortis du
système soviétique même si il ya eu des
reliquats etc
c'est quand des gens qui ont été formés
déjà dans une ukraine indépendante avec
d'autres avec le contact avec le temps
qui compte qui ont commencé très tôt les
gens qui ont rejoint massivement à
l'armée donc dans ce qu'on appelle la
défense territoriale ou à suis assuré en
fait les arrières donc c'était un appui
mais tout ce qu'ils étaient capables et
qu'ils soient volés en fait prendre les
armes ont pu faire une formation et au
bout d'un certain temps peuvent
rejoindre l'eau frau donc effectivement
il ya une volonté de combattre il ya
toute cette réserve des gens qui vous
des pilles 2014 on passait par la guerre
à un moment donné donc tous ces
réservistes qui est qui ont massivement
afflué il faut pas oublier que 200
milles et craignant qu'ils sont revenus
fantômes qui sont revenus en ukraine
pour combattre il ya encore des réserves
on n'a toujours pas déclaré la
conscription donc donc donc l'ukraine à
une volonté une réserve de se battre et
puis chapitre cité commises chaque chose
découverte aujourd'hui
fais monter cette rage de vaincre parce
qu'on comprend qu'on peut vraiment c'est
résister pour exister et qu'on ne compte
pas reculer et qu'il faut en finir avec
avec avec cet ennemi est celle de guerre
on va continuer de s'appuyer sur votre
retour d'expérience mais composées à
quand un calme et de nous rejoindre ce
qu'on parle comme assise parlementaire
rebond soit il ya eu d'autres
initiatives depuis le début de cette
guerre exactement on parle notamment de
sel et autour du président de la
commission et bien aidé les affaires
étrangères la défense et des phares âmes
est au début du mois d'avril et ils sont
allés en roumanie ces sénateurs il était
aux côtés de nos forces comme on dit
projeter sur place des militaires
déployés sous la bannière de l'otan bien
sûr pour rassurer l'allier romain et
montrer un peu les muscles os 6 1 face
aux russes il était donc inconstante à
200 km de la frontière avec l'ukraine il
ya là bas un groupement de soldats
déployés dès le lendemain de l'invasion
russe est alors lorsque les sénateurs
ont visité le campement eh bien ils ont
pu comme ça aussi donné un message de
soutien à nos forces militaires sur
place regardez c'est un extrait du
reportage on forme un réalisé par fabien
eckert
500 chasseurs alpins qui font partie de
la force de réaction rapide de l'otan
projeté en roumanie dès le début des
frappes russe en ukraine
vous avez fait le mali lie à l'allemagne
on enchaîne rock live
j'ai tenu à venir sur place pour voir un
peu d'abord les conditions voir dans
quelle
dans quelle organisation ils étaient
placés puis vous dire notre confiance
quand même parce que onu moi je me sens
un peu responsable du fait que vous êtes
là on voit que les crédits on donne
l'autorisation la prolongation et tout
donc c'est n'importe quoi on soit vous
pétez voilà à la clé à la france devrait
être à la tête comme ça d'un
commandement de 1000 hommes sur place en
roumanie cette visite avec donc pour but
un peu de contrôle et sur pièces et sur
place c'est ce que fait le parlement met
donc surtout pour soutenir les
militaires en parallèle les sénateurs
ont également rencontré des officiels
roumains ministre des affaires
étrangères de la défense ou encore comme
vous voyez sur ces images à leurs
homologues du parlement des visites on
peut le dire thomas qui sont largement
symboliques mais importante pour
signifier aussi notre amitié avec ces
pays et également pouvoir témoigner de
la situation sur place une fois de
retour en france écoutez nouveau
christian cambon notre souhait c'est de
voir d'une part comment la roumanie
procèdent et comment la france peut
aider ce pays courageux à accueillir
ces réfugiés j'allais dire s'est déplacé
dans l'espoir qu'un jour ils reviendront
chez eux il était important dans ces
temps de crise de prendre la mesure de
l'impact excessivement négatif est
dangereux de cette nouvelle de cette
attitude russe qui n'est pas franchement
nouvelle du reste mais qui se manifeste
de manière excessivement violent voilà
donc un déplacement en roumanie qui est
un pays clé on le sait un qui avait déjà
passé des centaines de milliers
d'ukrainiens c'était 600 milles au début
du mois c'est sans doute déjà plus les
sénateurs et qui ont rencontré aussi des
ong qui gère les passages de ces
réfugiés pour mieux comprendre les
besoins sur place et aussi des besoins
de ces populations qui sont accueillis
en france thomas merci quentin ce
reportage roumanie au aux portes du
conflit craignant un reportage long
format de famille avec elle il est à
voir à partir de demain sur notre
antenne sur l'antenne de public sénat
claude malhuret sur la question des
réfugiés on sort alors il ya un effort
qui est fait en france mais on se rend
pas forcément bien compte de ce que ça
représente
à l'intérieur même de l'ukraine et puis
dans les pays limitrophes
oui je pense qu'on se rend compte quand
on vous dit qu'il y a 5 millions de
réfugiés où l'on parle de 8 millions
paille à des réfugiés intérieurs et les
réfugiés extérieur par contre on se rend
compte assez facilement sur place parce
que vous avez des vous avez des files de
véhicules
qui se sont eux qui font des kilomètres
et des kilomètres il faut 24 heures 36
heures pour passer la frontière
et ce qui est le plus étonnant
actuellement c'est que les files de
véhicules elles ne viennent pas dans le
sens de l'ukraine vers la pologne
puisque c'était la frontière polonaise
qu'on a traversées elles viennent de la
pologne vers l'ukraine c'est à dire que
le nombre il ya déjà un million de
réfugiés qui sont qui sont revenus
reviennent et qui continue à revenir
deuxièmement 2 à 2 1 on remarque que je
ferai c'est que du poilu le l'aide
humanitaire aujourd'hui on a rencontré
le maire de lviv qu'elle a conduit
l'entrée de l'ukraine qui nous dit
l'aide humanitaire les fantastiques ya
des convois entiers et c'est donc je
pense que de ce point de vue là il ya
plus de besoin absolument fondamentaux
parce que tout le monde dans tout le
monde deuxièmement il ya des centaines
d'associations ukrainienne qui se sont
spontanément pour aider pour aider les
réfugiés en revanche ce qu'il nous dit
c'est que dans toutes les villes du coin
qui aurait été épargnée par le conflit
c'est là qu'ils ont pas dans la région
du nord de khair ou dans leurs pages ou
dans le sud on a transféré des blessés
civils et militaires dans les hôpitaux
et notamment dans les hôpitaux de lviv
et il nous dit lassé de la chirurgie
c'est de la chirurgie de guerre c'est à
dire c'est des blessures absolument
épouvantable c'est des reconstructions
de chirurgie de reconstruction est là
bien entendu
cette chirurgie là elle coûte
extrêmement cher d'abord elle nécessite
mais les ukrainiens en ont beaucoup
d'aidé des chirurgiens entraîné mais
elle nécessite des des appareils du
matériel extrêmement coûteux et c'est
peut être aujourd'hui me disait-il ce
dont ils ont le plus besoin parce que ça
sent la bonne volonté du public la bonne
volonté des gens qu'il faut en tirer
querrey qui réunissent de l'aide
humanitaire
ça ne suffit pas il faut vraiment d
des institutions dé confronter des
coopérations entre hôpitaux etc et
aujourd'hui c'est sans doute peut-être
là qu'il ya le plus de mains parce que
des blessés civils et militaires des
enfants des femmes des hommes il y en a
énormément
vrai qu'on revienne sur la question de
des défaites de l'armée russe vous
l'avez évoqué rapidement tout à l'heure
benjamin haddad mais il ya deux éléments
d'abord un chiffre selon le portail de
statistique allemand stati star l'armée
russe a déjà perdu près de 2800
équipements militaires de 1771 sa date
du 12 avril dernier set cette
statistique et puis on voit aussi sur
les médias sociaux les réseaux sociaux
ces photos de veuves de guerre russes
qui pose avec des billets de banque à la
main les voilà ces photos dix mille
roubles ça représente 133 dollars c'est
ce qu'elles ont touché pour la mort de
leur mari 133 dollars pour ce que
poutine présente comme les héros de la
nouvelle russie irina dmitri chine que
sait-on du moral des troupes russes
aujourd'hui c'est sans doute difficile
de répondre à la question mais que
sait-on du moral de ses troupes de ses
soldats alors on s'est appuyé sur les
captures des conversations donc les
soldats passent coûte-t-il qu'ils
passent à leur famille donc et ça ça
montre quand même que la situation n'est
pas brillante d'abord ils se plaignent
de 2 du fait oui oui se trouve dans
l'ignorance de me traitement que leur
commandement alors leur inflige mais
aussi du fait que les ukrainiens se
battent qu'ils
résistent et que donc eux ils ne savent
pas ce qu'est ce qu'ils font là ensuite
on a quand même ces faits de pillage
lorsqu'on a également montré les envoie
dans dans dans l'es1 sibérie ou dans les
pays lointains éloigné de la russie de
matériel électroménager etc et donc ça a
choqué les ukrainiens de voir à quel
point on a emporté les petites cuillères
les l'électroménager les sanitaires etc
on découvre aussi du gros matériel
agricole qui a été ce qui c'était un
grand vendeur des
combats en fait des machines agricoles
américains qui étaient équipés de gps si
on les retrouve et de la ville de milito
paul les aurait trouvés en tchétchénie
donc donc en fait on on voit que l'envoi
de et le pillage est absolument
institutionnalisée et ce n'est ce n'est
pas quelqu'un qui met juste dans sa
poche quelque chose donc c'est à dire
que ces couverts par part par les
hiérarchies donc ça montre qu'ils ont
aussi un côté de ses troupes qui sont
démoralisés qui en fait se font ce qu'il
ce qu'il ce qu'ils veulent en même temps
on est on est pas du tout dans
l'angélisme où on est conscients du
nombre que représentent ces troupes de
des réserves qui peuvent mobiliser dans
l'ensemble du pays puisque on sait que
ses troupes sont galvanisés d'abord par
des années de propagande et puis par les
dernières semaines et tous les discours
qui est déversée donc sur toutes les
chaînes russes et qui montre aussi qu'il
est devenu pratiquement impossible à des
familles de parler avec avec leurs
membres de la famille en russie etc où
on observe ce double double phénomène
parce que cette galvanisation
l'évocation du souvenir de la guerre
patriotique de la russie en tant que
forteresse assiégée ça mobilise aussi
les troupes le danger d'une troisième
guerre mondiale est grave
et nous ne devons pas le sous-estimer
qui dit ça c'est sergueï lavrov le
ministre russe des affaires étrangères
le danger d'une troisième guerre
mondiale est grave réel ne devons pas le
sous-estimer benjamin haddad comment il
faut analyser cette cette déclaration de
sergueï lavrov il faut la mettre dans la
continuité des différents types de
menaces qu'on a entendu de la part de la
russie depuis le début du conflit
l'agitation de la menace nucléaire si
une tentative de déstabilisation
d'intimidation qui est essentiellement
destiné à notre public au public
occidental et il faut pas se laisser
intimider ou ébranlé déjà serré partie
de la rhétorique russe et soviétique
avant eux de tout de suite brandir
l'armé nucléaire la menace de la
troisième guerre mondiale c'est quand
même un signe de faiblesse c'est à dire
que ça montre aussi que l'armée russe
est en déroute sur le terrain est en
fait il faut avant tout regarder
l'attitude de la russie sur le terrain
c'est à dire que on voit au contraire
les russes qui sont en train de reculer
il y avait un débat chez les occidentaux
au début de ce conflit donc déjà il ya
la question très clair qui a été
tranchée de ne pas intervenir
directement de ne pas devenir co
belligérants c'est pour ça par exemple
que la question de la zone d'exclusion
aérienne qui était demandé au début par
le présent est né ce qui a été rejeté
par l'otan parce que là on se risque est
de se retrouver dans une confrontation
directe entre des avions de l'otan et de
l'avion russe dans le ciel ukrainien
donc et moi mon livre ont de plus en
plus d'armes c'est l'une des amenant le
statut et devient bac commercial qui a
eu un débat il ya une distinction un
petit peu artificielle est
essentiellement symbolique avait été
faite en armes défensives et ram
offensive mais qui n'a pas beaucoup de
chance on monte en gamme effectivement
on livre des armes plus lourdes pour que
les ukrainiens puisse se défendre mais
en revanche effectivement on ne rentre
pas dans le conflit on ne devient pas
kobe géant assas unis qui sera pas
franchie par les américains ou les
européens met donc au début il y avait
eu des tentatives de déstabilisation de
la part de la russie là qui visait je
crois à s'assurer en tout cas que les
occidentaux ne rentre pas directement
mais quand on regarde en fait sur le sur
le terrain on voit que les russes au
contraire sont pas dans l'escaladé qui
sont en train de menacer la pologne ou
d'autres pays de l'otan au contraire ils
sont en train de de recul et de se
redéployer et de se refocaliser
effectivement sur le dombass et
marioupol dans la continuité entre le
dombass et la péninsule de crimée donc
la question de savoir si les russes
allaient tout d'un coup brutalement
escalader avec des armes chimiques ou du
nucléaire tactique alors fait dire ça
avec énormément de prudence parce qu'au
fond on est peut-être qu'au début de ce
conflit ils me voient au contraire que
le rapport de forces sur le terrain
fonctionne et que les rues sont en train
de reculer donc c'est du registre de la
rodomontade
pour on va dire grossir les musclés et
nous faire peur mais mais sur le sur le
terrain en tout cas les rues sont en
train de reculer il revient à dmitry
chine ça peut cette menace faut
peut-être aussi longtemps dans la
perspective de négociations qui
continuent plus ou moins ou qui
pourraient reprendre c'est une carte que
brandit
je pense qu'il faut voir comment elle
est russe manie les négociations c'est
peut-être souvent pour eux une manière
de faire traîner le temps de serrer
déployer de prendre d'autres et
territoire pour ensuite venir et sur les
positions de force dans les négociations
donc et je pense qu'aujourd'hui pardon
de interrompu il y avait cette image de
sergueï lavrov à côté d'eux du
secrétaire général de l'onu si on avait
l'impression que c'était de deux mondes
parallèles qui avait pas du tout la même
vision de discours qui était totalement
opposée qui pouvait absolument pas
dialoguer d'une certaine façon tout à
fait puisqu'il nous a remis la menace de
que la russie a ressenti comme si un
pays de l'otan ou ou le temps où
l'ukraine avaient l'intention d'attaquer
la ricine inverse complètement les
choses comme si ce n'est pas la russie
qui avait commencé la guerre comme si ce
n'est pas elle qui est en train de
d'avancé sur le territoire de bombarder
de payer de violer et c'est donc donc
c'est je suis d'accord avec vous c'est
absolument hallucinant de voir ce
discours et le secrétaire général a
quand même dû dire bon d'accord vous
appelez ça l'opération mais non on sait
que c'est une invasion et et nous
l'appelons une personne claude malhuret
vous étiez à butch a notamment la
semaine dernière on va on va en parler
ensemble et je voudrais d'abord écouté
le témoignage de deux habitantes de
cette ville martyre
nous vivions bien gucia était agréable
et propre et il y avait de l'ordre puis
ces bâtards sont arrivés et en un mois
ils l'ont transformé en je ne sais quoi
que dieu le punisse pour le reste de
leur vie la chose la plus terrible dans
ma vie et que mon mari mon être cher est
parti je ne sais pas ce qui pourrait
être pire sans fouiller dans les
cadavres ne me fait plus peur me paraît
à la tragédie de ma vie
ce serait un réconfort de l'enterrer de
pouvoir se rendre sur sa tombe ce serait
bien mieux que de ne pouvoir leur
trouver du tout je suis croyante et je
vis avec l'espoir qu'un jour dieu le
ressuscitera et que nous nous retrouvons
je vis avec cette pensée qui m apporte
du réconfort
claude malhuret sont des récits des
images qui vont peut-être rester vous
hanter pour longtemps
c'est aussi des chiffres bout de chat
avant la guerre 18000 habitants
il y a dix jours 1500 habitants et
aujourd'hui 3000 habitants parce que les
gens commencent à revenir mais au bruit
une ville qui passe de 18 mai
d'habitants 15 cents habitants voyez
l'importance de choses c'est évidemment
aussi des récits c'est vrai aussi du
maire debout de chat qui s'est caché
pendant hantise qui était recherché par
les russes qui s'est caché
pendant plus presse près d'un mois
il ya des gens qui ont été torturés pour
leur faire dire où il était ce qui
évidemment il était il avait le soutien
de la population j'en viens été torturé
et évidemment que s'il l'avait trouvée
il aurait été immédiatement fusillés et
ne l'ont pas trouvé personne assez cdc
en même temps des témoignages
bouleversants comme ce qu'on voit là et
en même temps des témoignages de courage
et de et de résistance
qui sont absolument admire irina dmitri
chine est ce qu'il ya beaucoup d'autres
bouts de chats puisqu'on sait nous
occidentaux focaliser sur cette ville
mais il ya beaucoup d'autres villes
martyres en ukraine par le café on parle
d environ 2 quai du nord de l'ukraine
d'où les troupes se sont retirées et où
donc les enquêteurs la police l'armée
peuvent peuvent travailler debout de
sharon stone mais le mac arrive hier
ping mais on pense aussi à ces villes de
l'est et notamment à marie paule où on
sait que le travail de nettoyage par les
russes a déjà commencé lorsque on essaye
de d'enterrer les cadavres de les brûler
de retirer les cadavres notamment du
théâtre pour les dissimuler donc donc on
pense à la fois à ce qu'on découvre et à
ce compte probablement née découvrira
jamais que manu rées il y aura
certainement des procès on sait pas
jusqu'où ça ira et qui sera jugée mais
on parler de diplomatie parlementaire
tout à l'heure à quoi ça sert une
diplomatie parlementaire et est ce que
vous avez vu les deux questions en une à
l'oeuvre des enquêteurs est ce que
c'était aussi pour ça que vous y alliez
pour prendre un peu conscience de ce
qu'est ce qui s'est passé là-bas oui
bien sûr mais je dirais que la
diplomatie parlementaire comme on le
voyait d'ailleurs dans votre reportage
tout à l'heure
elle a un côté éminemment symbolique
c'est ayant un côté politique symbolique
ça veut pas dire que c'est pourront que
ce n'est pas du réel mais la côte est
éminemment politique d'abord parce que
quand les ukrainiens
voit que des parlementaires
européens viennent viennent les soutenir
c'est dans une dans un pays qui est en
train de résister s'appliquait pendant
quelques semaines s'est demandé s'il
allait pouvoir résister ou non c'est
ainsi d'un soutien extrêmement important
et puis
on y est allé également comme je sais
pas si on l'a dit déjà mais on y allait
pour inaugurer la maison de l'europe oui
c'est quand même et ça c'est extrêmement
symbolique que vous avez des des
ukrainiens qui ont mille autres choses à
faire est en train de mener la guerre or
pour nous accueillir il faut une
logistique il faut des soldats qui nous
protège et c'est qu'ils ne
s'accompagnent et on prend on prend sur
les forces sur les forces armées pour
accueillir des parlementaires si on le
fait c'est bien entendu parce que ça
paraît important aux autorités
ukrainiennes et si on est une longueur
la maison de l'europe avec le maire avec
la maire de kiev c'est évidemment parce
que le message le message qu'ils nous
demandent de porter ces nous sommes
européens c'est
pendant ce temps n'étant guère et
pourtant on est en demande cette entrée
dans l'europe qui à la fois montre à
quel point en ce sens européenne et en
quel point le sentiment européen en un
mois ou deux mois
qui était déjà présent en ukraine mais à
quel point il a augmenté et deuxièmement
c'est le symbole du dire non seulement
on est européen mais revenons en au sein
de la russie c'est que ça commence à
suffire comme ça ça fait déjà fait huit
ans qu'on est en guerre il ya des
élections de la crimée ya le don de base
mais mais mais ça suffit comme ça le
maire de kiev c'est vitaly klitschko
personnage
17 pas là pour le rappeler qu'il est oui
c'est l'autre héros un finalement de
cette guerre les médias français l'ont
beaucoup pas interviewer il répond
toujours de façon positive également
camp des politiques se déplace le 14
avril dernier il avait même accueilli
anne hidalgo donc évidemment que il est
toujours d'accord quand il s'agit de
parler à l'opinion occidentale et en
ukraine c'est une star une star
extrêmement populaire pourquoi parce que
c'est un boxeur champion du monde
multiple champion du monde avec un
palmarès très impressionnant et il a
décidé d'entrer en politique une fois
qu'il est mis un terme à sa carrière
sportive en 2013 et il est devenu député
pro européen tout de suite il s'est
distingué notamment pendant la
révolution de maiden et faisait partie
de ces tribuns qui montait sur la scène
pour haranguer la foule et il a même
pensé en 2014 à se présenter à
l'élection présidentielle pour
finalement se rallier à porochenko et
donc c'est un homme qui a chevillé au
corps bien sûr sa carrière sportive mais
son engagement politique et donc il a
été une mère de kif et oui en 2006 il
avait déjà essayé sans succès mais là ça
fait deux fois réélu deux fois maire et
c'est vrai qu'en 2018 il avait confié au
guardian que c'est finalement c'était
plus facile d'être le champion du monde
des poids lourds que mr parce qu'en
politique il n'ya pas de règle on vous
frappe dans le dos sous la ceinture et
c'est très dur on imagine aujourd'hui il
pourrait encore en dire davantage et il
a ensuite
après l'invasion russe troquer cette
baisse de mer pour le treillis militaire
louis il l'avait dit avant même que les
russes n'entre en ukraine il avait dit
je suis prêt je suis prêt à me battre et
il le fait avec son frère son frère qui
est une autre figure emblématique par
jumeaux son frère jumeau voilà de la
résistance en ukraine je crois pas
qu'ils
se ressemblent énormément et comme celle
1 ce qu'il a refusé d'être exfiltré
comme celle inscrits ils se servent bien
sûr de sa popularité mais aussi des
réseaux sociaux parce que je vous
entends parler de valmy de cette notion
de nation qui est né à valmy notamment
pour la france mais ici on comprend
aussi que la nation ukrainienne est en
train est née elle est là elle est
puissante mais elle se fait aussi grâce
à toute la communication des réseaux
sociaux ils postent régulièrement
notamment sur twitter avec son frère des
vidéos des photos bien sûr pour
interpeller à chaque fois l'opinion
occidentale juste concernant lavrov on
voit aussi qu'on est vraiment dans une
guerre de communication parce que hier
soir je reçois comme beaucoup je pense
quand on est on est abonné à ce titre
d'information on est beaucoup de
français à recevoir ce message qui dit
troisième guerre mondiale extrait on
voit le choc que ça peut créer ou des
regards du recul les ukrainiens ont
aussi compris ça c'est à dire qu'ils ont
le sens bien sûr du devoir patriotique
ils ont le sens de la guerre mais aussi
de la guerre de communication irina
mitri chine qu'est ce qui représente
vitali klischko pour l'opinion publique
ukrainienne c'est l'autre héros
effectivement c'est comment il est perçu
il a une image extrêmement positive
parce par son action parce qu'il a eu
une brillante carrière en tant que
sportive il mène une carrière
politique était très apprécié dans la
capitale et c'est quelqu'un qui je pense
mérite parfaitement cette popularité
parce qu'ils s'y engage pleinement il
était toujours accueilli vos moments de
houleux la ville était assiégée ils
étaient tous les matins on le voyait
donc à tous les endroits qui ont été
bombardés où il y avait besoin de
d'intervenir donc il était là à consoler
alors que ça aurait pu être fait par
quelqu'un d'autre il aurait pu rester
dans son dans son bureau il était
présent sur le terrain et ça ça forge
quand même l'admiration oui il faut pas
sous-estimer effectivement dans les
premiers jours du de l'invasion l'impact
que ces images que ce soit celle de wild
thing italie jean claude kitsch co
pardon ou celle de vos l'honneur
zelensky dans l'opinion craignent elles
servent que les leaders étaient là se
montrait se montrer à la télévision se
monterait sur les médias sociaux et ne
fuyez pas à quoi c'est très basique ce
que je dis mais ç'a eu un impact évident
il ya eu aussi ceux qui ont fui et ça ça
a été tout à fait mise en comparaison il
y avait on voyait très clairement qu'ils
étaient qui étaient là qui était prête à
défendre l'ukraine et ceux qui ont fui
et d'ailleurs ça a été très clairement
indiqué envoyer bien quel parti
politique elle appartenait quel était le
rôle dans la société donc ce contraste
était aussi en faveur de ce qui est ce
qui est ce on estimait claude malhuret
il est il est doublement impressionnant
vitali klischko parce que c'est un de
mes 3 c'est ça ces molosses oui pick up
il a écouté son frère ils font tous les
deux la même terre
c'est absolument important d'ailleurs
quand oui moi je suis pas
particulièrement bons mais j'étais avec
des sénateurs qui seront occupons plutôt
un mètre quatre-vingt-cinq etc et ils
ont l'air donné un côté c'est vraiment
absolument est impressionnant patience
oui mais
après tout le bon vous me direz napoléon
était tout petit ça ne l'empêché pas
d'être napoléon mais quand vous avez des
leaders comme ça c'est vrai que la
charrue ça ça rassure aussi et
tant mieux tant mieux ça vaut bien le
panache blanc d'henri
duparc directement à ce qu'ils ont ils
ont combattu fait la pige quoi avec
yoann allemagne son frère aux états unis
donc donc il ya toute cette connaissance
de sociétés occidentales qui qu'il met
au profit de leurs actions au jour
d'aujourd'hui
et ils ont ils ont gagné leur argent
aussi par le sport donc de façon
transparente c'était vraiment aussi
quelque chose de très important pour les
ukrainiens au moment de la révolution du
maiden quand vous aviez une classe
politique qui était totalement corrompu
est composé de l'iarc là vous aviez des
gens que ce soit zelensky par la
télévision ou klischko par le sport qui
ont gagné leur argent honnêtement et ça
c'était vraiment je crois une dimension
assez importante et vous parliez du
maiden évidemment il faut jamais oublier
que cette guerre a commencé en 2014 avec
l'annexion la crimée les soutiens aux
séparatistes pro-russes du dombass
pourquoi parce que les ukrainiens
avaient voulu faire le choix du
rapprochement avec l'union européenne à
l'époque le débat c'était un traité
d'association avec l'union européenne
c'est pour ça que la dimension
européenne d'en parler claude malhuret
elle est si important toujours
aujourd'hui on parlait beaucoup de
l'otan avant le début de ce conflit mais
fondamentalement quand on regarde les
sondages d'opinion en ukraine vous avez
une très large majorité de la population
qui veut avant tout se rapprocher
l'union européenne qu'il voit aussi
comme la perspective d'un avenir
meilleur de l'ancrage de la démocratie
d'économie marché la fin de la
corruption dans leur pays donc là c'est
non seulement la responsabilité je crois
moral de l'union européenne d'ouvrir
cette perspective qui mettra du temps
c'est un processus long des réformes
l'état de droit des réformes économiques
mais au moins de reconnaître la
candidature de l'ukraine à l'union
européenne c'est un processus qui a été
lancé par la visite de la présidente
vendeurs la haine qui a donné le
questionnaire de candidature à vladimir
zelensky mais je crois aussi qu'on a un
intérêt stratégique à le faire parce
qu'on voit que le président hélène ce
qui est assez ouvert sur la question de
la candidature à l'otan est prête
peut-être à l'abandonner en personne en
échange de garanties de sécurité de la
part des pays occidentaux si on fait une
sorte de deal des changes où les
ukrainiens peuvent s'ancrer sur le plan
économique et politique à l'europe et
peut-être laisse de côté la question de
l'otan puisque de toute façon la porte
n'est pas ouverte là on peut voir aussi
les prémices d'un accord à l'instant
poutine qui dit monsieur gutiérrez le
secrétaire général de l'onu espérait
toujours un résultat positif dans les
négociations avec l'ukraine alors il ya
toujours un double langage à la charte
de vladimir poutine benjamin haddad mais
qu'est ce qu'on peut déduire d'une
phrase comme celle là rien c'est
simplement de la de la com
c'est de la com puisque c'est lui qui se
dérobe à la diplomatie des plein début
je veux dire aller par exemple zelensky
demande avant le conflit a rencontré
directement vladimir poutine il refuse
il y avait une dynamique peut-être avant
aussi pour relancer les accords de minsk
pour négocier sur la question de l'otan
aux élèves c'est ce qui est un
pragmatique quand il a été élu en 2019
faut se rappeler déjà c'est quelqu'un
qui parle russe sa langue maternelle qui
vient de l'est du pays et qui avaient
été élus essentiellement pour régler le
conflit avec la russie le mettre
derrière pour se focaliser sur les
formes économiques et la lutte contre la
corruption donc lui il est prêt en fait
aujourd'hui ce sont les russes qui ont
choisi la voie militaire donc si
solution diplomatique il peut y avoir à
un moment elle se fera avant tout à
partir de la réalité du terrain et donc
du rapport de forces sur le terrain donc
il n'ya pas de distinction en fait entre
l'option militaire est l'option
diplomatique c'est en accroissant la
pression sur les russes sur le terrain à
un moment vont se sentir coincé bloquer
voire qu'ils peuvent plus avancer et là
ils viendront à la table des
négociations on sera dans un pur rapport
de force dans parmi les déclarations du
jour c'est le 2 sergueï lavrov qui
disait aussi cet après-midi les états
unis veulent un monde unipolaire claude
malhuret ya ya plusieurs personnalités
politiques dont certains candidats et
candidates à l'élection présidentielle
qui qui ont pointé à plusieurs reprises
une responsabilité américaine dans cette
guerre en ukraine en parlant de l'otan
laissant l'otan s'étendent vers vers
l'est ce qu'est ce que ça vous inspire
du dégoût
ça fait longtemps qu'on a cette
cinquième colonne dans les pays
démocratiques dont certains sont
d'ailleurs directement stipendiés
subventionné par poutine qui nous
explique que c'est pas la faute
des russes que l'otan les provoque et
c'est alors que c'était exactement le
contraire qui se passe et on al'exemple
solution heureusement on s'est peut-être
un des aspects positifs de cette guerre
heureusement vient de découvrir que tous
les menteurs professionnels sont son
prix sur le sont pris la main dans le
sac c'est à dire que c'était bien
poutine qui qui veut que le cren ne soit
pas indépendante qui veut qu'ils pensent
qu'une crainte fait partie de la russie
que les crânes n'existe pas en tant que
nation dont qui sont aujourd'hui est
démasqué mais
ce qui ne les a pas empêchés d'ailleurs
de se présenter tous à cette campagne
électorale présidentielle évidemment ça
leur a quand même coûté à mon avis un
certain nombre de wailly compris
d'ailleurs au au plus haut plus obstinée
zemmour qui mais après l'invasion a
continué à défendre poutine tant mieux
de soins l'un mai
[Musique]
ce qui va leur arriver de pire et c'est
et c'est peut-être pour moi peut-être la
plus grande surprise qu'on va voir parce
que les gens ne s'en aperçoivent pas
vous savez quand la guerre a commencé le
25 janvier je fais un discours au sénat
le 1er mars et le monde ils vont
commencer par la phrase suivante
l'invasion de l'ukraine sera le premier
clou dans le secteur dans le cercueil de
la dictature de poutine comme l'invasion
de l'afghanistan a été le premier clou
dans le cercueil de l'union soviétique
et en est en train de à l'époque quand
j'ai dit ça ça pouvait paraître
absolument
étonnant on est en train d'appel de
s'apercevoir que la première partie est
en train de se jouer la deuxième partie
elle va se jouer à moscou
quand vous voyez la vidéo de 2,2 poutine
avec choïgou ya quelques jours vous vous
apercevez quand vous voyez qu'ils sont
en train de faire le ménage dans leurs
services de renseignements actuellement
quand vous voyez ce pauvre lavrov qui
n'a plu ou lisez tout à l'heure on avait
une faiblesse considérable qui n'a plus
qu'à dire c'est la troisième guerre
mondiale qui commence alors même que
c'est eux qui le et qui lançait mais ça
veut dire que ils sont sur le reculoir
et qui sont main je pense très
sincèrement que
l'hypothèse d'un brutus moscow libre d
un coup d'état lit peu d avancement est
aujourd'hui parce qu'il va falloir
rendre des comptes et que cette
hypothèse était run de jour en jour plus
plus que présente à la grande ronde
demain de ceux qui en france depuis des
années des n 10 que poutine est un
démocrate et que c'est byden et macro
les dictateur merci merci à